durant près de trois heures de cette
audition edouard philippe a nié tout
retard pris dans la gestion de la
pandémie expliquant s'être réuni avec
les équipes dès les premiers
frémissements
et puis il a expliqué qu'il ne disposait
pas d'un plan adapté vu qu'il ne
s'agissait pas d'une épidémie connu et
puis qu'il avait également été freiné
dans ses décisions
à cause de l'écart entre les règles
étatiques et la décentralisation extrême
qu'il était compliqué de piloter toutes
les strates décisionnaire concernant la
pénurie de masques et bien les documents
ne lui sont pas parvenus et c'est normal
explique-t-il
et puis les personnes âgées on n'est pas
de contrainte de rester dans
l'établissement plutôt que d'aller à
l'hôpital est bien pour lui
si elle y était venue et bien serait
plus surchargées les capacités
d'occupation de l'hôpital et c'est bien
tout problème puisque le gouvernement
avait dit que l'hôpital avait tenu
évidemment sans les personnes âgées
c'est plus simple concernant l'ue
l'inutilité du port du masque comme
souvent edouard philippe à blâmer les
incertitudes scientifiques
c'était sa ligne de défense vous propose
de l'écouter s'il s'agit d'intégrer des
éléments qui sont eux très strictement
médico sanitaires alors c'est plus
compliqué pour une raison simple c'est
que s'agissant des informations
médicales s'agissant de la
caractérisation de ce qu'était ce virus
avant on ne sait pas tout est le début
d'ailleurs je suis incapable de dire si
on sait tous aujourd'hui je pense que tu
as n'est pas le cas mais on a longtemps
on s'est longtemps posé beaucoup de
questions sur le fonctionnement non pas
la réalité du tout avec les prises en
compte très tôt et sur le fonctionnement
de ce virus chose importante le premier
ministre a justifié la tenue des
municipales expliquant qu'il n'y avait
pas de consensus politique ou
scientifique pour les ajournés et le
tout noyé dans un langage technocratique
voilà ce qui on peut retenir de cette
audition qui ne permet pas vraiment de
pointer les responsabilités de tel ou
tel